look a lot of us had a rough 2020. the
cowboys rougher than most as the nfl
goes but the pandemic really screwed
things up for a lot of people in a lot
of different ways in tragic ways for
hundreds of thousands of people and
their families
but what happened at the college level
was plenty of guys made the
conscientious decision not to play last
year for a variety of reasons the
uncertainty the lack of national college
football standards for the safety or
lack thereof that would prevail in their
weight rooms in their locker rooms on
their fields
and now we see the aftermath of that the
players who chose not to play last year
who opted out of the 2020 season in the
draft pool with the guys who did play
let's listen to jerry jones from
yesterday talking about how he and the
cowboys are viewing those who made that
very difficult decision to not play last
year
if you guys had not very much exposure
guess what
he may not have played last year they
couldn't but he didn't
okay he didn't because he decided to opt
out so you haven't seen him since the
six plays he ran when he was a sophomore
let's hold him while you're getting
ready to make that decision right there
how do you view players who did not play
last year or but really for
i'd rather much rather have seen the
reps and the plays that they've got
coach helped me here how many plays in a
normal situation would a
let's say a
defensive tackle
by playing last year as opposed not
playing last year if he had played all
of his college games i mean 71 plays a
game 10 games
700 plays 700 plus plays and plus
usually those players if they're the
type player you want
or are better from their junior to their
senior year fair fair to say absolutely
for what you look for
and so the point is it's uh
you don't have as much information when
they didn't play last year
[Music]
look
we talked about this yesterday on pftpm
and i got myself a little cranked up
about it i'm going to get myself cranked
up about it again today kevin colbert
the steelers gm explained in a very calm
dispassionate voice earlier this week
that if all things are equal between two
candidates they're going to take the guy
who played last year over the guy who
didn't play last year even though they
fully respect the decision
of those players who
who decided not to play in 2020 due to
the pandemic
i
i feel like
and and
you could this is one of those issues
chris that would be a good topic for the
debate club in high school because you
could make persuasive arguments on
either side of it sure is it good that a
guy played last year
is it bad that he played last year is it
good you know for a running back or a
defensive tackle is it good that he's
coming to the nfl with more tread on the
tires that could be viewed as a positive
if what we saw from him in 2019 was
pretty damn good and we didn't see
anything last year he's the same guy
yeah maybe he needs to be in a little
bit better shape but that's what we do
we get guys in shape but we've seen what
he can do yeah and and and maybe he'll
be even better than he was in 2019. we
like what he did in 2019 maybe he'll be
even better maybe he's still improving
so i
i just keep coming back to the fact
that football at every level not just
the nfl but at every level
they want robots
they want guys who are going to do what
they're told to do they want guys who
aren't going to stand up and push back
against the momentum
that shoves them toward the field and
anyone who exercises that independent
thinking that original thought that
movement that pushes against what coach
and team would want him to do
those guys get red flagged because we
don't want someone like that keeping us
from doing what we're trying to do on
our football field i feel like that is
the message that is subtly or not coming
through in what jerry jones is saying
well i i i don't like totally dis i
don't disagree with that i think there's
some of that there you know but hey i
mean mike you know put yourself in their
shoes it's the business of football i
mean yeah they'd like to see people who
play football to you know acquire
more information see where the guy has
gone as a football player so i
understand it i mean if it's apples to
apples
yeah i think if i'm in their shoes too
playing gm and you're going wait okay i
gotta let's just say you know for lack
of a better number i got a 7.0 grade and
a 7.0 grade for two players that are
great all right well this one played
last year this one didn't and yeah i'm
gonna take that you know even though
you know
the big what if he's a running back what
if he's a running back it's better than
he didn't play last year okay got more
reps in him at the nfl level
maybe that that could be a rare case
you're right that can be but i could
also say you know it was one less year
on him getting better at running routes
or learning how to pick up a blitzer or
doing other things like that that again
these are young kids who are still
learning the sport so you've stopped
that learning curve a little bit and i
think that's where it just scares teams
you know coaches and gm's and owners
they're very conservative that way right
so
they want all the information available
it scares them to a degree it scares
them when it's apples to apples and
that's what's going to be interesting
about this draft because as we get
towards the end of the first round you
know first rounds about elite players
some of these teams are going to have no
choice you're going to have guys where
you're going to go do you want a guy
who's super talented and didn't play or
a guy that's not that talented and did
play and you're going to hear
then the excuses of why we should take
the guy who's super talented and all
that and sat out but but i i understand
you know airing
or i guess airing erring airing i'm the
guy that that played last year than the
guy that didn't
they didn't hesitate to take jalen smith
with a completely wrecked knee no it was
risky right sat out a whole year right
and there were questions about whether
he could ever play but they and see
there will be a point where andy gregory
great player becomes value
and when you're sliding around too and
maybe that's what happens they're
compromised meaning they're going to be
drafted they're just going to be drafted
lower than they would have been but you
know what's going to happen you're going
to have some teams to get some pretty
damn good players because they're going
to understand it is a case-by-case
determination but
i still think this
this presumption that it's a bad thing
if you didn't play last year yeah yeah
we understand why you didn't play and we
respect your decision but now we're
going to hold it against you and i can
boil it down like this we had that great
explanation from nick saban earlier in
the week and i wrote something about it
yesterday and and it hits the nail on
the head and it's a great message for
anyone whether you play football any
other sport or no sports at all you are
going to be evaluated at some point for
employment for
admission to a college program
post-graduate whatever
and the two most important words when
people are making decisions about you
are and and but yeah
the question is and think about it think
about it if you're asking a gm or a
coach or an owner right now
if if the opt out
is part of the story that is being told
on a player it's not and he opted out
it's but he opted out the negative
connotation it is right no one's going
to say and and he chose to take care of
his family and he realized that the
science was uncertain and there was some
vague evidence of people having heart
damage as a result of it athletes
seasoned athletes highly conditioned
having heart disease as a result of it
so it's not you know that's an and but i
feel like it's being couched as a butt
not as an and that maybe tells us
everything we need to know about how
these teams view guys who opted out well
yeah yeah i mean yes and listen i i i
understand it to a degree again it's the
business of football and you know you're
you're looking to acquire
guys that are good at that business
which is playing football and you're
making big investments into these
players so with that
hey
they do want
you know and again yeah they want a guy
that that did play that they feel is
comfortable like man he wants to play
football at all costs you know i hope
they're not holding it against you know
these guys to a certain degree but yeah
i think when it's like that they're
gonna favor
the guy that like you know we've we've
joked about over the last few weeks the
mike tomlin quote you know i i want
volunteers right you know i don't i
don't want hostages i i mean everybody
is looking for that in the nfl so that's
part of this conversation of this nfl
draft but you know at the same time too
you know jerry said something
interesting there as well where he's
like you know hey
more times than not too a guy that you
look at as a junior right and he's a
good football player i mean almost 98 99
times out of a hundred
the guy gets better the next year he's
getting bigger he's growing as a man
he's getting more mature mentally i mean
usually all wigs it goes in that
direction unless there's like an injury
involved there's something like that too
so that's where it's going to be
interesting to see you know who who
balances that whole high wire act there
with this whole conversation that it's
going to be fascinating for thursday
night
i think the more accurate explanation
than we want volunteers we want guys who
have no regard whatsoever for their own
physical health and well-being and who
will play that way on the football field
because when they get injured and they
will we'll scrape them up and we'll put
somebody else out there but at least we
know that when he's out there he is
playing with the kind of reckless
abandon that will allow him to get the
most out of his skills and what better
way to prove
that he has no regard for his health and
safety than to play college football
during a global pandemic at a time of
high uncertainty the only certainty for
him was he loves him some football and
he's going to go play and i really do
think
that is implicit in all this the
combination of it shows how much you
truly love football
and
it shows that you are willing to fall
into line with what the coach the
organization
wants you to do at all times and i do
think it gets viewed as a negative even
though it shouldn't because they're
looking for
a highly talented individual
who will do whatever they want whenever
they want however they want and they
never have to pull the rip cord on the
lawnmower he's ready to go at any given
moment no matter the circumstances and i
think that even though it shouldn't be
this way opting out is sort of a litmus
test for some of these teams on how much
a guy loves football and i hate to even
say it because i think it's wrong it is
wrong but i think that's how they're
looking at it i mean i i mean they're
you're right they are
the biggest thing though is it's going
gonna affect the middle class of the
draft and those guys more than anything
you know again hey jc horn played what
what was it pete a few games this year
and then opted out oh guess what mike
he's really talented nobody cares you
know that's not a conversation for him
right so the super talented ones kind of
just gets like swept under the rug like
well
doesn't matter like he's pretty awesome
all right you know and and that that
it's going to be more about the
splitting the atoms in the third round
and that's where it's going to affect
those players where it's like oh we got
two wide receivers one played one opted
out let's go with the one that played
and did that and i understand that too
again you know that's gonna be he he's
played more football he's had more reps
we saw him improve on the thing he was
bad at the year before we have visual
evidence that the guy worked and got
better at it you know so that there is
some logic of course to the way they're
thinking yeah i think there's a little
bit of a
you know what do i want to say a caveman
attitude a little bit to the like oh he
didn't play and now i'm not going to
take him because he doesn't love
football yeah of course there's that
part in the nfl with all coaches and
teams but i think more of this is about
you know the gathering the information
more than anything
yeah i i i think there's a way to spin
it if you want to into a positive i
think it's more of a but than an and
when they look at the scouting report
and bring up the topic of whether or not
the guy chose to play it last year i
think that's unavoidable it's just the
way it is
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports